well you want to do you want to break
the news cronkite or should i
well
we you know we have recorded this a few
days earlier so uh we've just discovered
pardon my uh i'm a little speechless
we just discovered that uh one of the
best comedians of all time nor macdonald
has died
yes uh one of the funniest guys on the
planet one of my heroes huge influence
on me i've seen everything i watch his
youtube probably every other day i just
went on when i first met you
and i saw you i was like oh he's doing
like a jerry norm thing
yeah seinfeld and norm where i think
gatel and dangerfield were my yes every
comic you'd see joe mackey was like
hedberg and eugene merman wow i could
you could always see who people were
kind of influenced by in their first
couple years and yeah and for you
it was norma mcdonald yeah i just uh i'm
floored i cannot believe this is real
i'm crushed i'm hurt i'm my body's doing
that thing where i it keeps avoiding it
my brain keeps avoiding it but then i
have to remind myself that it's real
it's crazy to discover this literally
maybe three minutes before we just
recorded it yeah a live stream app by
the way and uh oh my god i just one of
those guys you just never thought
this i had no idea i had cancer
61 61 very young he had another special
in him he's great on podcasts i i just
wish he made more and uh i mean look
he's got a lot of stuff out there so i'm
getting greedy but uh
i think he's one of the funniest people
i mean no one sounds like him
amazing jokes great takes
brilliant comic very sophisticated i
mean i still remember when he made it to
the i think he made it to the finals
on who wants to be a millionaire he made
it to the million dollar question and he
bailed because it was for charity but he
turned out he knew the right answer so
this is a guy who by all accounts was
like self-educated yeah and made it that
far i mean
really one of the best comedy minds of
all time i remember colin quinn told me
a story once that you know one of my
favorite musicians ever leonard cohn
being a canadian would go see noy
mcdonald play whoa
and no one was like who's this guy who's
this old guy
he didn't care that leonard cohen was
norman
wow
unbelievable yeah his gambling stories
on howard stern are incredible i read
his book i've just i've seen everything
he's done this is dirty work is a great
comedy i love dirty work i met him i met
him once at the seller and i got a photo
with him and now i'm so glad i did he
did uh last comic standing he was the
only honest judge he would tell comics
they were hacks it was awesome uh the
comics hated him joe list did it and he
goes joe you're a very good writer and
anthony justin goes hey joe that norm
just called you ugly which is such a
great line
i met him twice and the first time i met
him was i was doing this comedy-style
competition
at caroline's
and it was the final four it was me dan
soder who eventually beat me in the
final two
it was me soder
nick cobb and adam newman wow
uh
norm macdonald was just chilling in the
crowd watching damn and he couldn't have
been nicer he was so freaking nice to
all of us yeah complimenting her axe
being like man i could never do this
type of thing you know
so cool and then the other time i met
him was on last comic standing when he
was a judge and i got eliminated
in the first round uh i had a pretty
good set better than a lot of people who
moved on but it's nbc let's face it
but
i remember i had one joke that norm
single down goes that joke is gold and
that to me was wow it was like it was to
me i i didn't even feel that bad i got
locked off because i was like norm
mcdonald who is the judge that i
connected to his work the most it was
roseanne and kean i connect to
roseanne's politics of course
but uh but it was roseanne and keenan
and ivory wayans and like obviously i
love him living color but norm i'm a
comic norm was the guy i connected with
and
the joke he loved was i said you know my
last girlfriend was a hoarder and she
broke up with me which which stings
extra hard i'm like the one thing she
can get rid of
and he said he loved that joke and then
uh
i got
keenan kind of digged me in the in the
last comic thing he said you know i like
some of your jokes but not all of them
ah and i said well i loved all your
scary movie films and it got a huge
laugh
and he i only did the first two and i
was like all right i remember i saw norm
and like the food
yeah he couldn't let it pass he couldn't
take the l and that one i was about to i
knew i was out after that right and then
i'm walking through the thing it was
like a break i guess they were taking a
break they paid audience and i see norm
and he goes i really like that you did
that you dug
so that was that was a special moment uh
he's the real deal he really is um
yeah i think he could tell and i said i
met you once at caroline's and i i told
him i feel like
yeah yeah he quinn said he's the him and
david spade are the funniest hang of all
time them together yeah i did last comic
with keenan was one of my judges as well
and uh he zinged me and i said
appreciate it damon and i got a big whoa
yeah but i got kicked out
we both gotta we both went down swinging
yeah as they say exactly
yeah i mean norm really was brilliant i
mean
not just his stand-up but i mean an edgy
underappreciated weekend update oh the
best the easily the best weekend guy and
he followed i believe he followed kevin
nealon mm-hmm who i thought was great as
well was great yeah different type of
anchor yeah dennis miller was always
like lauded as the best one and then i
feel like norm kind of took it over norm
was our guy it's almost like almost like
people like i'm a letterman guy and and
then we're like well we're conan guys
right
that's kind of what norm was but he
would come in and he would bomb a lot he
would have jokes that the audience would
be like oh he had this one great joke
he's like something something women are
bad drivers and they went oh and he went
well i want you to know a woman wrote
that joke and they went oh and he went
i'm kidding we don't hire women
that's a comic
he just kept teasing him that's a
[ __ ] combo he went this way that way
then that way i mean he's he's the best
before we go on i should say that we're
not drinking alcohol this week uh we
decided we've been doing so many day
episodes i'm gonna go ahead and say i
don't like getting day drunk i'm a night
drinker sure we work at night it's hard
being groggy for these sets all the time
yep yep we decided they go we say we
might be drunk we're not saying we are
drunk
the titles we might be yes and this week
we're doing coffee but it feels weird
not drinking now no
i mean i might pull off pull that
angel's envy off this shelf and have a
have a toast because
it's the we should do we got to do a
shot for him we got i think we drink
coffee but we do a shot at it it's irish
baby he's irish mcdonald canadian grew
up on a farm
dad was a
whatever his mom was a teacher he comes
from humble beginnings
red dostoyevsky i mean he had a son he
lived in an apartment in l.a ate cereal
for dinner can't drive
i relate to that right there yeah
yeah it's uh it's a huge blow huge loss
and we literally just found out before
recording this well should we play i
mean let's play a couple great norm
clips as is just to honor him and yeah
his greatness here here
all right this is by request
norm on letterman his last time doing
his world war ii joke yes i love this
trick this is where i met him at the
seller he was running this
but i watch the tv i watch the news make
you afraid the news you know put all
these stories on iraq iran north korea
you know try to scare you you know but
does it ever really scare you like you
ever wake up in the middle of the night
ah north korea
that little tiny country across the
ocean
i wonder if they'll get me
plus didn't mash settle that like 20
years ago
why'd they have to watch that's a stupid
show
there is one country that worries me
though not iraq not iran not north korea
the only country that really worries me
is uh the country of germany
i don't know if you guys are history
buffs or not but
[Applause]
in the early
part of the previous century germany
decided to go to war and uh who did they
go to war with
the world
i've never been tried before
and uh so you figure that would take
about five seconds for the world to win
but uh
no it was actually close
then about then about 30 years pass and
uh germany decides again to go to war
and again it chooses as its enemy the
world
and this time they have that guy can i
kindly that guy
i'm not even gonna dignify him by saying
his name but i think you know
but you think at that point the world
will go listen germany
here's the deal you don't get to be a
country no more
on a county you keep
attacking the world third time
you're
mars or something
okay
there it is ah
i got missed it i'm getting misty yeah
it's a great bit i mean it's so it's so
simple those are the best bits the ones
you're like how has no one done that i
know
the world
oh god i'm a [ __ ] queef i love when
when you do a joke that's like uh the
setup
it all hits the crowd at the same time
yeah i don't know if you guys are
history buffs it all just hits them i
mean that's that's a great amazing
that's a beautiful way to bring
an exact feeling to everyone in the ed
sullivan yes here here well said that's
a great point yeah he was he was the
king he was the best i mean if you could
play the
the chairman of the board thing is
probably his crown jewel and his panel
because he had so many great panama the
moth joke uh all that [ __ ] but
the one with the snl because a lot of
comics like i don't give a [ __ ] i say
what i want
this is the ultimate not giving a [ __ ]
he goes on he gets fired from snl he
gets rehired to host years later he's
like really okay he he's always hated
them because they fired him so he comes
back and tanks the whole show in the
monologue and then just does the show
the balls his return monologue you mean
yeah yeah comes back
all right let me do this yeah start
doing the coffee sorry we'll move on
from norm but i uh i'm freaking out here
so yeah i think you were touched by this
a little more than most people mark yes
uh-oh he said put it on ten oh god
we might need peters oh we can figure
this out what is this
yeah good grind not his first time on
grindr
oh just about to go there
not his first time on grindr
that doesn't look good looks like shake
a bad weed
oh my phone's blowing up
who wants to talk about it everybody
every comic you've ever heard of
i get a million insults on youtube
comments and i always get i thought this
was norma mcdonald and then when i
realized it wasn't i turned it off and
i'm like i get it yeah
i did i did a bit once that they were
like that's annoying i didn't know i had
to pull it i was i was wow yeah i mean
that hit and i was like it was got the
good bit and then someone was like
that's a norm bit i'm a fan i was like
[ __ ] i pulled it yeah yeah well that's
very flattering that you're thinking
like norm
whoo he got in trouble remember he
defended somebody and he got in trouble
and it's like go petty what was it it
was very petty and uh it just ain't
gotten trouble for saying uh down
syndrome or something yeah but either
way it's just like doesn't this put it
all in perspective this guy is dead now
it's like he defended matt damon as they
recall i think it was matt damon it's
like you can't do that you can't do that
that's where we're at all right uh
matt's coming in matt peters everybody
the producer you get to see the man
behind them more trouble than it's worth
at this point oh god just pour it in the
filter see what happens yeah no i'm
choking but these are from guatemala jj
roaster sent these in so thanks jj it's
good coffee i had some at home
we don't know i don't know what's going
on here
come on oh what do you got your nuts
with you what's in the bowl
ah
that might be it
yep
there we go
hey boy
you guys seen all this 911 stuff
yeah man i got sick of 911. you're sick
i i i
i mean i feel like bin laden here i'm
like all right enough
we got it i don't think he was sick of
hearing about it i think he was like i
think that was his crown jewel ah good
point uh
and a baby boy we are worthless
comedians are worthless comedians not
making coffee ah
salacuse is on today
is that working whoa
it says brew now the light is on so i
think you're good did you set that clock
you so the clock so the clock is right
on the coffee thing there's not one
clock in america on a coffee machine
that is correct
mine says 9 11 on it
afghani
[Laughter]
yeah it's working there we go sounds
like anthony hopkins in silence of the
lambs right now you hear that
um yeah man norm is one of the best ever
should we do some more that's kind of
loud isn't it i don't think they might
pick it up
hello the chairman of the board yeah
let's do the chairman of the board bit
norm
so uh one of you guys want to set this
up well he's on with an actress courtney
thorne smith
who is who i think was from melrose
place right yeah and she
is in this movie with carrot top who i
guess was making a lot of movies at the
time oh yeah called chairman of the
board and norm is the was the first
guest and he hangs around
so here you go
okay
but uh
if it's got carrot top in it you know
what a good name for it be what's that
norm box office poison oh my god
there's this movie coming out
title undetermined at this point
chairman of the board
oh
all right do something with that
i i've got the board to spell b-o-r-e-d
out of the chair i mean come on that is
unbelievable i wish they let the laughs
go a little longer they shorten it but
yeah
um incredible you know as a comic we've
all been in that moment where they're
like what do you got now i mean you get
you you handle hecklers all the time
you're swatting flies all day long when
you think of that line when conan
challenges you and you deliver it's
pretty damn cool and also i mean this is
very much
i get mark relates to this as saying the
inappropriate thing at all times this is
i mean so much of like what i related to
as a comic growing up was dangerfield
right in the hoity-toity scene being
inappropriate right i mean right you're
the disrupter is the comics so i mean i
i love this [ __ ] oh it's the best and
then to have that line and he nailed it
i mean to put that much pressure on you
on tv and nail it i mean
it just proves that he's uh on another
level
b-r-e-d come on and pull that out of
your ass that is something and then the
delivery he's so excited he's like like
a 10 year old i bet it's called brdd
it's like oh it's so funny
god that's him already
damn
brutal yeah we have all the footage at
least but jesus will never get anything
i mean he he was a true comic legend i
mean so many comics
revered him he was he was a comics comic
and it's rare for those guys to break
through and have the mainstream success
that that norm had but yeah
he really did you know yeah he i mean he
had a lot of failed pilots but he kept
getting the pilots because i think
he was one of those guys i think even
the suits were like nah he's good like
yeah yeah he had that kind of pure
tall good-looking guy
uh
great observational could work clean
kind of had all the tools of what a
mega star stand-up should have but he
was just so dry and such a disrupter
right that would get in the way
sometimes totally he had that his sports
show i'm not even a sports guy and the
jokes were so good like he was killer on
that great show yeah just nobody cared
about sports on comedy central i guess i
remember he did a bit that defended
tiger woods
uh that i thought was hilarious on the
show and the bit was basically like how
many well he's like yeah he cheated but
think about how many women hit on him
he goes how many women hit on you in
this many years he goes one in 10 years
he goes tiger had like this many hundred
he only slept with this many right he
did the math he goes he's more faithful
than you are
that's a great it's a great angle for
everybody angle great angle and then
people nowadays hear that and they go
well that's a little low and you're like
it's about the angle you come guzzler
it's about the joke the tools the the
spin
it's a magic trick and he pulled it off
it's not about the
uh the politics and all that that's what
i love he was a contrarian a lot of a
lot of great comics are like well you
think i think it was more like the media
was tearing tiger to shreds and even
though we can agree what he did was
wrong
i think he he felt for him and that was
his way of being like i feel for this
guy that is being railroaded like when
do you see the tiger dock you kind of
you do feel for him sure of course so
what was that thing he did was wrong
slept with a lot of women with like 20
women behind his wife's back
yeah i mean that's no him just [ __ ]
those women is if you're not married i
think that's but you know
she made out okay financially sure i'm
sure she's got other issues yeah yeah
yeah there's nuance to the picture and
he added nuance that's what i think
that's what i took from the bit good
point well we do a thing now where we
just deem somebody like he's bad so like
tiger woods was bad and then to find a
way to make him okay is really brilliant
that's hard comedy well yeah that was he
was finding
an unorthodox angle yeah which i loved
about it insane same like tasha's joke
about how slavery is kind of cool
and you're like whoa oh hey how is he
gonna get out of this one and he does it
and it kills and you're like
he probably doesn't it's not like he's
pro-slavery i'm guessing he worked that
one out in beverly hills
i don't think he worked that one out in
atlanta i don't know i think i saw him
in compton
yeah but you see my point the the the
skill is to get out of that to set it up
and get out bill burr has a lot of those
sure when you get out if they're
clapping in the setup it's not exactly a
thrill
it's not as exciting yes
yes exactly
so jesus he'll be missed i still can't
believe it's real
uh i got a bad news after i drink this
i'm gonna [ __ ] all over you okay because
i can't not [ __ ] after a cup of coffee
that's all right i mean that's that's
what it does right yeah i love it i love
i like the consistency of my morning i
wake up i make my coffee and i take a
[ __ ] there's something comforting about
that routine i do the same exact thing
except i have oatmeal now do you read on
the [ __ ]
i admittedly i do a lot of phone
scrolling
i'll read the news but like okay i yeah
back the days of me reading a a
a hard hard cover yeah in the book it's
like you know so our apartments are kind
of small do you [ __ ] with your fiance
and your girlfriend in the house yeah of
course door open
live live feed yeah she's actually a
door open and i have a fan blowing in
her direction no i uh
no we uh
yeah of course
some of the romance
yeah i mean he's doing on her chest
she's from germany but the worst uh no
uh
you know
what do you mean i mean you gotta poop
in your apartment what do you think i'm
gonna go to the [ __ ] corner store or
like wait till she goes out to do
something
i guess
it's a bold move hey uh can you take a
walk i've got to take a dump like that's
that's a bit aggressive too isn't it
yeah one word candles
you light a candle yeah it's almost like
a little remembrance you flush it it's
like a little memorium now it smells
like my ass and sandalwood so that's
kind of nice
now uh
for sure i mean also here's a little
here's a little secret that i've learned
from the ladies poo pourri get that
little spray you put it in the toilet
before you poop no smell let me ask you
this you got a bidet
no do you no everybody's got a bidet but
us we're the only three people in
america without a bidet they seem nice
they seem great they used to get mocked
for a bidet but i feel like now that
they're green they're green right yeah
yeah it's kind of nice too like i don't
i feel like you're not fully wiping the
ass without a bidet it's true i mean
they make a good case you wouldn't wipe
[ __ ] off your arm with a dry towel i
mean i do but i wouldn't do it normally
but the bidet is the gay marriage of of
uh toiletries why is that because it
used to not be accepted and like a few
people were into it and now everybody
likes it and it tickles your [ __ ] oh
but i'm just saying it's come around
it's tough that the [ __ ] tickle is
now part of the bedroom because then you
take a [ __ ] you get a little harass yes
yes yeah your brain is confused yeah
yeah but i always read during sex
oh yeah we're all confused this is a lot
of [ __ ] calls yeah matt we might have
gone overboard here this is ten cups
three of us yeah what are you doing is
for the aaa meeting after i mean this is
a full pot
pol pot bad dictator
word association here
uh for anyone who doesn't who questions
that mark is autistic
trying not to think about normal i am i
am the photo can we move
on my youtube page is a thing that says
mark norman on norm mcdonald it's like
30 minutes of somebody compiled me
blowing norm and just made it a video
so that's that's where if you want to
you want to hear me talk about him it's
there it's and just watch there's a
great challenge i saw he retweeted one
of your jokes oh i reposted it on
instagram it meant the world to me yeah
he uh he has a
youtube page called i'm not norm and
whoever made it is like some super fan
and it's so well done and it's got all
the best [ __ ] so check that out
i'm not norm
it's rough man what should we try to
talk about i mean let's try to talk
about upbeat stuff maybe i don't know
yeah
you have a good weekend and any good
wrecks for me i got a ton of stuff oh i
watched malice at the palace pretty
great i loved it it's incredible man
yeah on netflix it's uh it's only an
hour and eight minutes so yeah if you're
looking for a great short dock uh
it's terrific it's you know i remember
where i was when that happened it was
such a shocking moment the fight in the
palace but uh yeah our test or now metal
world peace jermaine o'neal stephen
jackson it's great it's great
so well done and uh oh it just shows
like the media can spin stuff and uh
these poor guys went through hell o'neil
was was on the course to be a big shot
well he was a great player but i think
that really hurt him oh yeah i think
like
you put in that kind of work and your
teammates keep taking the wind out from
under your sails you know yeah i got to
give a shout out to the guy who or the
gal whoever directs these things
the new one with marty fish have you
guys heard of marty fish
wait
i like the cream first
sorry
tell me when
a little more help there it is
all right this guy marty fish
is a tennis guy and he's just a regular
guy but he got to like number one in the
world and then he had a mental breakdown
and lost it all but these untolds are
made the bruce jenner one this one mal's
in the palace the christy martin one
they're incredible whoever's doing these
deserves
the bruce jenner one's incredible
incredible because you never hear that
side of him you know because caitlyn
came through here we go hey
to a new beginning here here for sober
episode matt do you want some coffee
oh it smells pretty damn good guatemala
baby
mmm covered
that's really good that's good coffee
wow shout out to jj roasters for sending
this to us hell yeah i love it man man
that is good and that oat milk is
hitting the spot oat milk underrated
milk uh the best milk it makes me it's
like you ever you ever date someone
you're like they were great and then you
you date someone after like oh no
they're great yeah that's what it feels
like the transition from almond to oat
milk oh i thought almond was good and
then i was like i'm in a [ __ ] yeah and
i'm glad almonds over because we got
through all those
ain't no nipples on an almond ah
we got it i mean it's like everyone has
it everyone has it yeah too much how you
milk a note there's no nipples on a note
yeah yeah yeah
so marty fish
yeah just a fascinating guy because he's
a guy like us but he got wrapped up in
this he played tennis as a kid just for
fun yeah and then he started getting
competitive and he did okay he was
friends with andy roddick they would
compete whatever but he would he would
he lost 10 games in a row to andy
roddick he was just he was a friend and
then one day he just said you know what
i'm pretty good at tennis i'm gonna
change my whole life work out every day
and become the best and he just did it
and then he started beat he beat nadal
he beat all these guys it's unbelievable
it's just a thing flipped i mean his
wife was like i mean it ruined our
marriage like he was out every day
practicing and he said he would just
tell a guy serve the ball to me that on
that side and then that side we're gonna
do that for like four hours and then
they would go jog and then they would go
work out i mean it's unreal he just had
something flip and then he went crazy
that's crazy that you know
you pursue what you do what it takes to
really be great and yes and the toll
it's never nothing it's always
it's always something pretty extreme yes
it's hard to have it all so i don't want
to give away the ending but he's on his
way to the u.s open the
top elite against djokovic or whatever
his name is the best in the world
and he's having a panic attack in the
car on the way there on the limo and his
wife goes
this is bad i don't you know you don't
have to go and he was like i don't
and he just went home wow on his way to
the open
insane
wow
cool doc check it out untold the whole
series is killer yeah i liked it yeah
these sports docks are really they're
fun docs were just kind of a thing like
you'd see a dock every five years back
when we were younger and now they're
like taking over
and movies suck
it's one of the few i mean netflix
doesn't have a lot of good original
shows but then the docks they have are
pretty strong oh yeah oh yeah killing it
even the 911 was great i jerked off to
it you jerked off to it
that's one of one of the best uh
oh that's a yeah louis
you could tell how good a person you
were by how long you waited
to to jack off after 9 11 if he said for
me it was in between the first and the
second
uh tower yeah pretty great between the
first of the second that's great
dude i remember jerking off on christmas
morning once and feeling horrible about
myself really yeah yeah i did it for the
jews
uh before but i could hear my
grandparents downstairs and it was like
family time and i was like i gotta rub
one out real quick i was like 13 14. and
uh you have no control over your penis
in 13 14. no the penis controls you yeah
you just wake up with a stiff one you're
like oh [ __ ]
and no present was as good as that uh
that tube suck i filled
that was the one year you were happy you
got extra socks for christmas
oh [ __ ] how do you know i needed these
right i hung that stocking up it was
hard
holy gee what are you doing sally
christmas masturbating oh
this is gonna get us kicked off youtube
presents but i got
we don't need a visual for everything
man
we can we can just visualize some of
this
uh the worst part was the candy cane up
my ass but other than that it was a it
was a great time uh
yeah dude i mean
that not only i can't watch any 911
stuff i'll tell you though i'll tell you
the one movie i think uh handled it
tastefully was 25th hour oh yeah
movie where they're just kind of at
ground zero and there was actually new
york times article about this last
weekend about how that was like the one
movie and that's how i felt i remember
seeing the theater and it's uh philip
seymour hoffman and barry pepper just
like looking over
because all these movies were editing
the twin towers in at the time and it's
like what the [ __ ] are you doing this is
like the opposite of being a holocaust
denier you know what i mean it's like
right it's weird it's like what do you
put so that uh
yeah you always say that no jews in the
building it's like i think they were
jews in the building
right what are you talking about that's
always the big conspiracy about 911
there were no jews in the building just
saying that mossad took it down right
and they they warned all the jews like
they have time to do that yeah do you
believe that of course not yeah i mean
[Laughter]
i mean
i don't know
yeah i just think uh i remember that day
i mean you were here right really yeah i
remember it he has a photo of him at a
bar drinking after yeah
wait what would you do who are you like
11 school yeah i remember my dad did
take me out of school we uh i remember
had a teacher give us a pop quiz
uh
like we found out that that the
one tower minus two
i was like look in her defense this is a
math class so i don't know but uh
no she was a spanish teacher and we were
like [ __ ] you we were all like we're all
screaming at her like we're not taking
this and then she gave us she was like
pop quiz we're like we're under attack
and i just wrote [ __ ] you on the test
whoa
i got an f but uh yeah yeah i was like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i don't know if my mom's
okay right
yeah crazy man this is my photo from
i woke up oh let's see it connected i
woke up uh hungover i was in college and
i walked downstairs and it was tough
times at the norman household just me
being a piece of [ __ ] and i walked down
my dad goes uh something horrible has
happened i was like oh god did i wreck
the car did i drive through the front
lawn did i do something and he goes uh
look at the tv and i was the towers were
smoking i went oh thank god oh because i
thought it was me
but then i tuesday thank god you didn't
get a dui and 911 happened you really we
really lucked out yeah selfish [ __ ] i
wrecked my dad's car like a week before
and i was blacking out a lot so it was a
tough time but obviously uh
that took precedent over there yeah man
you know uh i remember i mean we all
lined up to give blood but the lines
were too long i mean that was like
that's how amazing new yorkers are in
times of crisis it's like we all lined
up to give blood and they're like nope
we have too many people already we're
set yeah we tried a few hospitals there
was no one to give blood to yeah at some
point because no one was coming in uh
he was injured right remember how much
we love firemen that was like the
firemen heyday that time yeah well
firemen are still pretty beloved i think
yeah but they were they were like in the
front limelight
i love watching the docks too because
you hear the accents like
31st floor you know you gotta hear it
it's great like thick irish brooklyn
fireman accents yeah good times
yeah man i remember that day when it was
crazy really really terrible but
uh
hot take
i take yeah
i don't want to divide anyone here
911 was bad i will say there was some
unity amongst the country for once well
because it was us versus them yes it
wasn't us versus each other i know i
hate it yeah the division yeah like the
division i mean we liked rudy giuliani
back then that's right until his entire
presidential campaign was 9 11
9 11 9 11. that was literally every
lineup there were like compilations were
like yeah dude we know who you are
yeah rudy had a hot minute in new york
oh yeah oh yeah he was big
broken window theory that was his
what's that that's like
it's when uh you have cops
uh on little petty crimes
right and that leads to cleaning up the
city if you catch a guy who's jumping a
turn style he's also someone who's going
to rob someone
in the subway
the idea is if you take care of little
things the big things will follow yes
you get the seed broken windows broken
windows theories
uh
yeah something like that but it seemed
to work because crime went way down but
they also did the stop and frisk it was
i got first once did you yeah i think i
was the guy they were like get him in
it'll help optics
someone diversity worked in your favor
against you i mean against me yeah uh
hmm yeah i got a good wreck for you boys
oh i love you nobody holds a coffee cup
like this the morel i mean look that's a
real writer right there really that's a
good that's a good hold on i do but i
just always hold it like this i guess i
don't know pro hold i'm like like a
dweeb with the handle this looks a
little weird too yeah but the above
and the side that's good
um
here's my wreck
old movie not old old but from i believe
the late 80s called the fabulous baker
boys oh
jeff bridges bow bridges
no michelle pfeiffer
uh it's basically it's the it is like
the best movie about
comedy that's not about comedy well
isn't this like train robbing no that's
another movie oh i think it's something
else um
this is they're a
a piano band they're they're in a they
play piano together jeff and bo bridges
and they can't sell tickets there's so
many great scenes where they're like
trying to get paid at the end of the
night and they're just they're trying to
get gigs and and there's a c in the
beginning where they hand them an
envelope and jeff bridges goes count it
count the money like that like they
don't they're always getting shortage
great scenes like that been there but
there oh yeah and then there's um
they're kind of struggling to get
bookings and bo his older brother says
you know he's the more conservative one
he's got a wife and kids he needs to
provide for whereas jeff the younger
brother is he's he's more talented he's
more of an artist i mean it's hilarious
there's scenes where he's in like a club
playing
jazz you know and like black guys and
they have to get black guys and they'll
be like he's good
you got to put him over you need a black
guy in there to be like no he's good
right right ultimate nod
but
uh yeah but they're not selling tickets
so they're like we need a woman in there
michelle they she's an ex-prostitute
turns out has a great voice she goes on
the road with them and it kind of goes
from there it's really good wow a lot of
great lines there's a lot of great
one-liners the line in it where he's in
the jazz club and one of the guy goes
aren't you playing the sheridan or
something goes yeah it keeps me out of
trouble he goes and what are you doing
here he goes looking for trouble yeah
a lot of fun lines i love it i've never
thought about this movie i've heard the
title but i never knew this was about
shout out to ronan hershberger buddy
because he was like you got to watch it
it's like so like comedy yeah the way
they were doing the road and stuff
and the way they're hustling to survive
and uh and then i love these worlds
where prostitutes look like michelle
pfeiffer too by the way
where's that prostitute
they look like patrick ewing you know
um
well
i'm in it's great it's on youtube in its
entirety i couldn't find it anywhere
else actually but it's it's free on
youtube oh yeah yeah you got something
else
the fabulous baker boys i'm in great
good flick good pull you you don't mind
going back in a time machine and
checking it out it's like the late 80s
it's like i like gold something about
old movies gives me calm you know it's
like their their work
lives on i kind of like that it's not
even that old it's like the late 80s i
think but yeah i like really old movies
usually yeah yeah that's fun though the
80s were were very cookie cutter for
movies i think but this one seems
interesting i'm in any movie that i can
parallel with the wrestler crazy heart
this i like another another jeff bridges
crazy heart that's right i felt like i
like crazy heart but i feel like it was
kind of like the wrestler light similar
it was like the pg-13 wrestler right
the wrestling wrestler wrestler is
incredible incredible man something
about pro wrestling gives me like like i
was on the road this weekend and i was
sick and i was you know feeling like
crap in that hotel room and there's
something about being sick on the road
that's just so damn awful
and uh
i'm laying in bed i'm like what do i do
you ever when you're sick you just go
back to like childhood comforts i just
threw on like a wrestling match from
like back in the day then you like dig
deep in a youtube uh comment hole and
it's like how the wrestlers [ __ ] hate
each other
like that piece of [ __ ] didn't fall when
he was supposed to fall
gave me a concussion you know i love
that beyond the mat no i hear it's great
oh it's great yeah is that the one with
red heart no it's the jake the snake
sort of duck oh no yeah i didn't see
that i've seen a bunch of them but i
didn't see this one yeah they're doing
it they did the andre the giant they did
uh ric flair and they're doing a hulk
hogan one soon
i was never a hogan guy i wasn't really
either i was a macho man guy
oh
they all hated hogan they were like it's
funny i hear these things about the
political game how guys like hogan and
shawn michaels weren't as well liked
because they they played the politics
kind of they were very they were very
talented obviously especially shawn
michaels but like they weren't
macho man was funny i thought he was
funnier yeah oh yeah i like macho man i
like brett hart i liked uh
you know shawn michaels he was great
yeah yeah i liked that too i i liked
hogan because he was bald i remember
thinking like he this bald guy is is
hanging in there he had the long hair
with bald and and people still liked him
the long hair with balls are roughly
remember rushmen evie is every joke
where he goes how about a ball guy with
a ponytail it looks like all your hair
got together and hung itself oh
i love that that's a great job that's
great yeah man uh no macho man uh
was the best
yeah yeah there's a real darkness to
wrestlers like even beyond comics yeah
like the ro they're on the road harder
than we are and oh sure like imagine
think about how sore we are just from
flights and they're doing that [ __ ]
while like fake fighting and jumping
through tables and [ __ ] and the pills
and the booze and the coke i mean they
they go hard these guys and they get hit
with folding chairs they die young they
gotta hit the gym they gotta look good
they have to invent a character like uh
maybe
the rock and what's that guy's name
sean no mix
austin oh yeah he's probably the last
great character wrestler is there a new
one now that i'm not aware of no we just
don't watch anymore yeah there's good
people still we just
uh but that guy they throw he would
stood up on the ropes they'd throw him a
beer he would chug it they throw him
another beer he would chug it then he
would go back to the map i mean he was
he really was a spectacle yeah he was a
badass
don't forget goldberg
everyone hated that guy oh really well
anti-semitic no no no he was just a bad
wrestler he like he's the one who
injured bret hart oh like he didn't know
how to properly do to execute the move
so he hurt him badly hmm you can't you
got to learn the moves i think they
tried to push him into prime time like
all his matches were really quick
because he wasn't that good uh but he
was like the new character
it's almost like a tick tock comic doing
comedy clubs we were like he's good on
tick tock right
he doesn't have the chops yet yeah
strong guy but it's like you can't i
mean that's like a [ __ ] ballet for
meatheads almost it really is that's a
great way to put it ballet for meatheads
speaking of that i went to see jimmy
buffett at red rocks oh man how was that
that's why i needed this coffee because
i i've i destroyed my body over the
three days i was with bert kreischer got
it we did two ivs back to back how did
that help unbelievable you get why these
these rich guys do it because it's
[ __ ] awesome
the only problem is doing that [ __ ]
you're like you when you're that
hungover your body's like
please stop doing this i know and then
you get an iv and you're like i'm going
to keep doing this you got that right
yeah i was drinking a mimosa with an iv
in my other arm we went at it i did
shrooms at buffett
i'm not the hugest jimmy buffett fan but
you can't deny the good vibes look at
that i mean i was standing with 10 000
people
singing cheeseburger in paradise with a
[ __ ] shark hat on and a hawaiian
shirt and a grass skirt
and i was on shrooms with my lady we're
dancing
i'm with bert's wife and bird is is
hammered and chugging beers i mean it
was really a special moment damn
pretty cool looks fun super fun how was
it for you taking a night off comedy
not easy
but the shrooms helped
it's tough right yeah but then you feel
like i feel sometimes when i go to
another thing i'm like what am i doing i
know i should be doing stand up
the only thing i can kind of
zone out is like a knicks game
that's like the only thing i can like be
like well it's like my favorite thing
yeah but other than that you really need
to be captivated or else you're just
like i'm a piece of [ __ ] i'm guilty i
gotta get in there you know i love
baseball but it's too slow the whole
time i'm like i'm a piece of [ __ ] i'm a
piece of [ __ ] and here's the wind-up
yeah we went to that yankees game and we
got lit up just because i think got a
guilt i've got a question for you sam
sure you get to pick one of two things
yeah and you only get to see it once in
your life
the knicks win a championship or you
play msg
that's easy
well for you maybe nick's the next thing
i think he's gonna pick the knicks
well you're you're saying me or that or
another person i mean you can never see
one again you'll never see another
championship he's gonna watch the next
until he dies here's here's what i'll
say it's a good question championship
means less to me than just being run
competently
like i am okay with losing i just want
to lose like my favorite team ever is
the 90s knicks they never won like i
love the 90s yankees so much they won
i got my favorite team is a team that
never won so i'm i'm okay with not
winning
so i will i will probably choose me here
but
at the same time
i really do love that and also here's
the problem is like
oh that was a badass team look at that
the men were men baby yeah they
represented the city and they did it
with style oh yeah no they were they
were a great team i i just want to be
cool and competitive again also if they
get too good i'm never going gonna get
tickets good point i love mine but um
i do i mean look i really want to see
him win for sure but also it's like you
have to take a moment sometimes with
sports and be like does this really
affect my life right right you know
that's true good that's good i think
that's healthy
um
knicks are the one like i'm a knicks fan
and a giants fan a yankees fan and the
giants beat tom brady twice in the super
bowl so i'm kind of like i'm set on
football for life
and i better be
watching the giants the last few years
holy [ __ ] yikes but uh yankees too i'm
like set for life i got to live through
derek jeter and mariano rivera and jorge
posada and bernie williams and tino and
like those are like some of the coolest
teams ever like i love paul o'neil i
love those guys dude but
you know
the knicks they never won and i'm like
eh you know then you see some of these
kids who grew up like in boston where
their teams won every year they're like
20 in boston like oh you just never knew
what losing was like that's bad for a
kid yeah yeah you just become a
fair-weather little [ __ ] right i
hate fairweather fans i think it's like
it exposes lack of character like you're
like oh oh you're a dolphins yankees and
uh chicago bulls fan right yeah it's
like one of the things we're like oh
you're a fan of all the teams that were
the best when you were a kid and you
just stuck it out so you think that
means you have character was like no you
got to win right you're shitty i think
that like
i think like if you're a loyal sports
fan you're often loyal to like people
and i think it's other it's not just
that yeah it's like saying what's your
favorite restaurant mcdonald's burger
king and wendy's like come on man get in
there
how is it like that ah [ __ ]
well it's just an easy answer like oh
you like the one that everybody else
likes it's mainstream oh i didn't think
that was i mean i i my thing is like i
have friends who are like one of my good
friends dory i shut him all the time he
was like he was like he was a lakers fan
during the shaq and kobe era and now
he's a warriors fan
and i'm like you're you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] dory and he's gonna mad me for
saying this but i'm like dory and he'll
be like well i'm from the bay area and
i'm like but you grew up a lakers fan
yeah hey hey we might be drunk is
brought to you by honey
you gotta love honey i mean come on you
shop online we all do it you buy shoes
you buy groceries you buy toilet paper
and we've all seen that empty promo code
thing just taunting you and you're like
oh i've only had a promo code i'd get
half off or a percentage something but i
never have one who has that you go to
some
shoe brand you're like ah i could get i
could get a real discount here but i
never have it i always wonder who does
well now honey is the free browser
extension that scours the internet for
discount codes when you're ready to
check out honey automatically applies
the best one instant savings honey has
found its customers over 2 billion clams
in savings supported by over 30 000
stores online buy anything from tech
gaming beer wine you name it
i i saved on uh some sweet kicks
thanks to honey put that coat in
got a discount shoes are expensive get a
break tell them how to do it fatty
if you don't have honey
uh you could be straight up missing out
on free savings it's literally free
installs in just a few seconds save some
dough and support this podcast get honey
for free at joinhoney.com
drunk that's
slash joinhoney.com and get that honey
baby yeah
yep by the way i put spike lee up here
for a reason
i was watching his 911 doc that's on hbo
all the time now the one about the
levees oh that's katrina sorry it's like
uh new york over the last 20 years
basically yeah a second huh 15 part doc
okay
his daughter's in it
her name is satchel
like woody allen woody allen has a
son named satchel baseball player
satchel paid both named after satchel
paige wow that's funny the chances like
what do you both directors alter actors
both new yorkers interesting
both knicks fans i think the only two
kids in the country named satchel have
to be theirs no there's others there's a
couple satchels out there it's not even
a real name
it was a name
page i think that's a nickname i think
geez you know what i'm gonna name my kid
lou gehrig's disease
morale it's a long one
i knew a comic back in the day uh glenn
coyle rest in peace clan very funny guy
he said my girlfriend got lou gehrig's
disease so i traded her ah
i love it that's great he's a funny
bastard all right let me give you a
weird wreck
uh i'm off on this sip because this uh
it's like a norm thing it's brutal right
it's [ __ ] horrible horrible i keep
forgetting then you remember again and
you wanna
you wanna just end it all but uh
get yourself one of these and thank me
later
jam box
i'm talking a little bit little thing
you could the size of a coffee mug you
can put in your suitcase it's a speaker
speaker for your bluetooth little one
yeah one of those the smaller the better
bring it to your hotel room i like to
play my podcast out loud i play a little
music out loud not not too annoying
level but like uh not you know puerto
rican day parade but just like a little
tune and you play it in the shower
it's great i get into my apartment i got
in a hotel room
give it a shot it's good for a backyard
get yourself one of those jam boxes or
pills or whatever you call them
yeah they are good i like those they're
good they're underrated because they
they come in handy we we were sitting
out during a red rocks like in the in
the lawn and somebody had one i was like
thank god you have this thing they're
great it's crazy how good we are at
avoiding conversation now oh i was
thinking about that i was watching a
show on on the comedy central uh app
on my on my tv you're the one
but it had commercials uh-huh and it was
like so every time there'd be a
commercial my girlfriend i would like
talk about what we just saw i was like
oh we don't do that
right that's like it's like weird that
you're like oh [ __ ] i used to do this
with every show you'd watch something
there'd be a commercial you talk now
it's like literally the episode's over
starting next episode four three two one
you're like oh [ __ ] all right we can't
have a moment to ourselves we we freak
out it's anxiety yeah like when you have
an awkward moment the phones i mean that
the the little jam box thing too it's
like you're like you're hanging like
[ __ ] what are we gonna do yeah thank god
i got those noises yeah yeah no you're
right you're right i mean even you're
walking down the sidewalk oh you get the
red light i got four seconds i'll look
at my phone you know we all do it you
gotta we can't have a second i lost my
phone last week i left it in an uber
i was crushed i was walking around like
who am i where am i i didn't know who's
contacting me what's in the news today
it was it was a nightmare then i got it
back two days later but it was like
it was weird it felt like you feel
disconnected from earth which is sad
yeah no it's true and
these sounds there's something about
comfort when you're traveling all the
time like just noise even if it's a show
i don't like i just throw on like it's
like chopped on food network and i'm
like i don't even like watching this but
it's just there it's just there i'd
rather have like consistent than good
yes yes i feel comfortable i play a
podcast to go to i go to bed to podcast
because i just don't want the silence
damn it's not good yeah that's not good
i like it as a kid too i get wound up
as long as i do an audio book is more
company podcast is too how do you go to
bed there's like a mpr podcast yeah i go
like a serious one like freakonomics or
radio lab or something like that where
it's just kind of droney and i'm out i
can do like an audio book but i can't oh
yeah yeah that works i guess it's like
the same [ __ ] though but you're right
man we are uh we are juiced up we need
to be constantly entertained constantly
distracted i mean can you even imagine
taking a [ __ ] without a phone in your
hand oh
somebody once told me there uh they
didn't get back to me they're like sorry
i was [ __ ] i was like
who shits with that phone you're
obviously lying yeah
you would have seen that while [ __ ]
and wiping so i got him on that one but
yeah just think like 1996 we just took a
[ __ ]
just stared at the wall
usually you had a book or a newspaper
george carlin brain droppings or
something in there
right or you'd have books behind the
toilet oh i still have toilet books
calvin and hobbes how about the dirtiest
jokes or whatever remember those things
i love inappropriate oh man those got me
through i remember those jokes like the
dirty ones like remember the one with
the there's one of my favorite ones the
one the guy uh
he's shit-faced and he uh he comes home
and before he goes on the bartender's
like he's like my wife's gonna kill me
what do i do the bartender goes put a
put a uh ten dollar bill in your front
pocket say someone vomited on your shirt
because he vomited on the shirt he's
like no no just put and your wife won't
get mad he gave you 10 bucks for the dry
cleaning and he goes that's great he
goes home his wife's like what the [ __ ]
happened he goes someone vomited on my
shirt to give me ten dollars she pulls
it out this is a 20 goes he also [ __ ] in
my pants
great joke great dirty jokes like that i
love oh yeah i used to read those and
you don't want to get you get
hemorrhoids because you never want to
get off the toilet those were great it
was like pre-twitter you know
yeah those are great
why is my poop pink oh because this was
a good
book was that old one a guy kicks his
trailer door open his gigantic wife is
sitting on a barca lounger and the guy's
holding a duck and the guy goes this is
the pig i've been [ __ ] and the wife
goes that's not a pig it's a duck he
goes i was talking to the duck
and that's a that is just classic
classic comedy not mine i think that's a
new heart but
either way good times those books were
somebody had to think of those oh i i
mean you know what i love back in the
day do you guys were you familiar with
snaps oh what are you kidding come on
you knew snapchat i went to public
schools
snaps no they were like dude
that was the saddest thing i've ever
heard dude they're like they're books
they're books of insult
so i would show up to school people
thought i was a genius for a while
because i was in like second grade
rattling off insults like someone say
something like oh yeah your mom's your
mom's soldiers have milk in her tits
she's got sour cream and everyone be
like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah your mom's legs
are like peanut butter smooth and easy
to spread yeah compelled you to become a
comic
yeah i was
although i was a young i was a young boy
who was stealing the material of snaps
but uh yeah oh my god yo your mom's so
fat when she puts on high heels she
strikes oil
she's all right your mom's so old when
the gut said let there be light she hit
the switch
your mom's so dumb i said it was chilly
outside she got a bowl i mean there was
a million of them your mom's so fat when
she sits around the house she really
sits around the house
ah were better than others but yeah
someone great but they i mean man you
you yeah they lost steam but i think the
third book they were just like you're
like
they just got an advance or something
some of these are
some all the moms out there like what
did i do what the [ __ ] i know why
dude
we would rattle those off and it was
like oh yeah it was great same that was
like the new duel it was like you
weren't gonna shoot somebody but you
were gonna verbally yes go at them rap
battle almost yeah that was good stuff
everybody had them too everybody had
their their one in their back pockets
snaps what were the other ones you had
to make fun back then because i'm so
thin she could get a hula hoop and a
cheerio
dumb one but thin is kind of a
compliment your mom's you say skinny
thin is a complicated so skinny your
mom's so fat she uh she uses the equator
as a belt i think that was one
yeah
oh here we go when your mom's so
familiar she goes camping she hides they
hide their food that's funny that's a
good one
ah i'm so fat she stepped on a scale and
said to me continued these are clever
these are good i swear your mom's so fat
i swerved to miss her in my car and ran
out of gas that's good i remember that
one my your mom's so fat i slapped her
ass and i rode the wave oh that was a
good one that's a good one yeah strikes
oil there's yours wow
this is just sam's joke book right here
i'm so fat she brought a spoon to the
super bowl come on
play on words
snaps or do well on twitter oh your
mom's so fat her blood type is ragu
i forgot about that one they do that one
in the sopranos
i think that's apolly wellness
he says it again he goes you hear what i
said i said she's so fat her blood type
is ragu
he repeats it that's right
oh man your mom's so fat her character
in star wars would be admiral snack bar
that one's rough that is that's a long
way to go long hell of a reference hell
of a reference what about uh the ones
about the mom being loose are funny too
oh yeah
even rodney is kind of has like a but
they're about himself exactly yeah he's
like uh man i'm so fat uh
i dropped a oh that's a classic your
mama's so ugly she threw a boomerang and
refused to come back oh
29 your mom's so stupid it takes her two
hours to watch 60 minutes that's a
classic when i was a kid it was took her
two hours to make minute rice so that's
just a little skew on that one she put
air bags on her computer because it
crashed
it's not a good one
stupid is the harder one it's like a 60
minutes one it is like it is you know
look the mom it's like the mom is the
most offensive thing i'm like why aren't
there more father jokes but like the mom
is the most hurtful thing you can say
we're trying to sting here by the way
blonde jokes and pollock were big and
those are just over
they're not that they're not that good
they're not that good but it also shows
if you kind of like don't complain they
go away because you want to sing
somebody
so if you're like hey you pull up like
then you don't even do it anymore the
polish were too dumb to complain
there you go blonde jokes were big those
are over those are over
too many people are dying their hair now
ah that's true it's fake blondes yeah
hold on let me uh let me get some other
stuff you got a peeve
let me see i got one i did do this to my
girlfriend
uh i i got like i do this sometimes i
don't know why i do this a lot of people
i think do this but
i got we were getting a snack for the
movie and i had like a little pen on a
popcorn bag and i grabbed it and i said
all right these are all these might be
old even with the pen so i said let me
try i tried it i was like it's not good
and i hand it to her like for her to
confirm that it wasn't good ah
yes why didn't i just accept that it
wasn't good and throw it out i was like
you try the bad thing as well i do that
with milk sometimes i'm like i think
it's expired here yeah yeah you do that
yes we all do that that's an annoying
thing that i was like i i'm busting
myself now i'm not just calling out
other people's peeves i want to hold
myself accountable yeah this tastes
terrible do you try it yeah is this beer
skunk this is skunk did you always have
your friend try it yeah that's the thing
we do
i don't know if that's a peeve but it's
uh
if someone else does it it is i guess so
let's see what else yeah i don't know
what about this for a peeve you ever
have this one you ever make a good point
like you're you're kind of arguing with
a guy and you make a good point he goes
that's fair
no no i'm right
i'm right you're wrong that's that's not
fair i'm right that's the word his
wording suggests that but he's not
outright saying it he's found a way
around giving you complete credit that's
what it is i want the credit you know
you go two plus two is five i say no
it's two plus it was four you go that's
fair no no no that's correct
but yeah
it's just a tag on your peeve please
someone says am i right or am i right
that's oh my god
am i right or am i right you're [ __ ]
annoying
yeah good point am i right i should
[ __ ] sit on a pair of scissors am i
right or am i right yeah come on
this is kind of a smart business move
you can't you can't lose right am i
right or am i right yeah but you know
the person who coined that was like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh no doubt there's no
way that guy wasn't the worst yeah like
the per you how about the person oh they
go working hard or hardly working oh
clever thanks yeah that was big the
first time in 1804 when the guy said
that that was a real cheese dick who
said it was never a cool person right
right oh man those cubicle kind of like
office jokes or brutal
yeah a million dollars short of a
million dollars or whatever the [ __ ] it
was what was that one
you know that one
i'm a million dollars how are you doing
there yeah it's always how you doing
just give me a [ __ ] good i know just
say good keep it moving don't even say
yeah hey i'll give you hanging in there
because we're all struggling right now
that is like the process of like over
time it changes like 20s you're like i'm
good 30s you're like i'm hanging in
their 40s you're like you know right
right you know what i'm doing
that's bit potential that's a bit
potential potential this guy's all right
he's clocking bits how about this one oh
you just got in huh thanks for bringing
the weather with you
oh yeah
yeah that was me i'm storm from the
x-men [ __ ] all right right
i'm katrina and the waves all right you
got a bit
do you have do you have a p oh you
difficult okay yeah here's my bid idea
it's not much i just nodded down but uh
god damn getting the push notifications
now on norm
here's what i got jesus something about
like you want to get an adult woman in
the mood
just apologize to her that's what it is
now like nothing gets a woman more
turned on when you're like hey i've been
thinking about what i said to you
earlier and uh it really wasn't fair to
you
you know what i mean
like young women they used to they used
to they want to be taken to a concert
old women they just want you to swallow
your pride
that turns them uh yeah they're willing
to do that for them like right because
young women need excitement and and
adult women they just need a win right
they need validation you know what i
mean there's something there yeah yeah
for sure
you need a perfect example
you know like uh
you know if she's that crack in my neck
that was a doozy that's for real
what is a good uh yeah you know if
you're like you know what i don't take
you out enough for something where you
give in
and then you let her win
you know like oh yeah yeah i'm just like
kissing her and i'm like you're right
i really do have a lot of work to do in
myself or something like that yeah
that's hot that's dirty talk right there
because women want to know that a man
can improve mm-hmm
a great system they always want to
improve you they're trying to improve
you yes we're like stocks women buy low
and they just hope
you know sometimes you crash
yeah
yeah that's called divorce what it
really is we we crashed right
right yeah we plummeted yeah yeah that's
interesting
yeah they but the funny thing about
women is they want you to improve but
they're not really doing the improving
you got to do it yeah you can't really
do that with like a house or something
if you want your house to be fixed up
you got to fix the house but she wants
you to improve from the inside they do
work sometimes they're like what if you
did this they make suggestions
suggestions yeah but it's like hey how
about you you help me you come to
therapy with me you uh you teach me how
to do this and that can you imagine
giving your girlfriend or fiance one bit
of advice to get better how that would
go over i've done it and did it how did
it go over
uh she's dead now
no no she uh
she took it she's cool my my lady played
sports and i think that kind of helped
her a lot
they just toughened you up but like you
can take criticism
and she's one of those people like i
want to know i want to know like tell me
nothing worse than the ladies like am i
do i look fat in this and you're like a
little and they're like [ __ ] you it's
like well don't ask me
mark picks the wrong time to be a truth
teller yeah yeah no you're not supposed
to be the lenny bruce of how do i look
all right but if i look fat in something
i'd want you guys to tell me
but you know that you and your
girlfriend are not fat i know but tell
her that she doesn't know you tell her
that it's your girlfriend i did and i
got i got the waterworks
no i'm joking
i i uh
yeah i think there's some potential here
there's something here yeah for sure
i like that what do you got i got a i
got a lady bit too
um do you yeah i can hold on to your
penis
so uh as you would i've been with my gal
for a while now and you learn when
you're with a lady in the beginning the
private parts of the genitals and after
a while
when you're with a girl the pride parts
are kind of meaningless because you've
been there done that right the stomach
is the new private part you i touch at
my girlfriend's boob she's like hey how
you doing if i touch your stomach she's
like what the [ __ ] are you crazy oh wow
and you know it's like that is more
private now
than the uh than the tits you've proven
you're safe to the vagina right but you
need but there's it's much harder to
prove you're safe to the stomach yes
it's like the stomach lets you in and
you bypass the stomach to get to the
vagina and then you're on your way back
and they're like where the [ __ ] do you
think you're going
interesting well i've been thinking
about this bit and i think the reason
the stomach is so
private and secretive is because it
fluctuates
the boobs are kind of always you don't
fluctuate the vagina does over years but
the the stomach
you can have a bad weekend and the
stomach changes you can out you can go
off the rails with some cookies and some
ice cream you know and the no girl has
ever said oh my god my high school
reunion is coming up i gotta get these
tits into shape you know what i mean the
stomach though
it's kind of a barometer for where
you're at
sometimes the stomach gets bigger so are
the tips
that's true i think the thing that's
interesting is something about like
what's the thing that lets you in it's
easy to get in then it's hard to get out
there's something like that oh
interesting how does that connect it's
almost well because you cuz because the
stomach at first is not a big deal but
then you get but then and you go to the
vagina but then you're going back up to
me it's something about like it's almost
like a relationship it's easy to get in
it's hard to get out oh
i don't know i might be being too out
there with this one but like it's
interesting i see where you're going
okay let's go back to your so
because the stomach changes the other
stomach changes the stomach is like
where you're at yeah you go to the gym
to work on your stomach you're not
working on your tits at the gym right
that's my some people get their tits
reduced to work on their stomach at the
gym
right that's true yeah
i think i had something which is
both need to be filled to be satisfied
oh that was your line stomach
vagina
but you don't have to be filled
some gals like a nice uh philip a cream
pie no no i mean like dick size oh
yeah
now we're cooking that's a good tag
that's a good line
but i think there's something there
because the stomach changes and i think
that might be the the
official angle like the meat of the bit
don't touch my stomach yeah well there
even though
i've known you for years we've had all
kinds of sex we've done everything in
the bedroom but this stomach is still
like whoa jesus
don't touch that
it's kind of fascinating
stomach for the woman is like the
butthole for the man oh
now we're cooking like you can touch it
but you better give me a [ __ ] heads
up all right
now that's an angle
butthole for the man
that's the name of my album
i like it
it's true
all right moving on about norm again i'm
sorry yeah i know i get it it's tough
what a day ah brutal
life is tough life is hard all right i
just want to want to give a toast to
neil diamond
did he die no he's alive okay why why no
diamond i just think he's underrated in
general i love neil diamond i was going
to ask a question towards the end of the
pod which i think we're coming to right
sorry that came out of nowhere the neil
diamond thing um so people like norm we
didn't get to tell him how much we
appreciated him yes
in the last months before he passed and
i don't know even if he wanted that but
is there someone you could think of
who's alive right now that would like to
hear how much you appreciate them
i mean i just heard you say
uh
not new house what's his name
you mentioned bob neuer he's still alive
i think i think yeah he is i think he
still performs yeah you know i think
people know yeah he was so tight with
rickles who lived a long time as well i
think uh who performed till the very end
as well
yeah i mean
i think we tell them i think they know i
think the people we know know but if
it's comics like that that we don't pick
someone like you don't know like a new
heart who would love to hear it i mean
if he's listening or someone passes it
to him like oh older comics older comics
anyone it doesn't have to be a comic
could be
a director could be a writer it could be
a musician
excuse me
uh just wait until it's too late yeah no
one's gonna norm's not gonna hear any of
this stuff we've been talking about how
much we love them
yeah yeah i'm
not gonna do cosby
all right now uh let's see
yeah i mean comedy comes to mind but i
mean i just love i love quentin
tarantino i love scorsese yeah brothers
i love bill murray cohen brothers yeah
um i love lily tomlin man
is great yeah
yeah
yeah it's hard because there's so many
and it's hard to be specific but when
they die you're just zoned in on them
but it's a good point we always worship
people after they die
like is gonna sound dark and morbid like
david tell is one of the funniest guys
on the planet and he will die one day as
we all will
and i think he's gonna get
propped up and blown and
put on a pedestal as he should but i
think he should be have that more now i
wish everyone would go out and see david
tell on the road and i think they do i
think he does well on the road but i
think also just you should know that he
is one of the greats of all time and and
also a great guy but great guy dave is
see dave if you're on the road you know
uh support dave's comedy because he's
he's influenced all of us oh we love him
so much here here
yeah so a tell is a big one yeah cause
when he dies it's gonna be like genius
comedy savant blah blah blah so also you
never know what's gonna happen to
somebody like norm came out of nowhere
mullany goes to rehab
you know he could have been hurt like
you gotta just
everyone's got a struggle that we don't
know about that's the thing i'm looking
for uh
and as cheesy as that [ __ ] sounds
i didn't know norman mcdonald had cancer
i didn't either
for chadwick boseman we didn't know he
had children boseman who was a great
actor and only would have
he was going to be a mega star he was
going to be [ __ ] denzel
yeah
yeah there you go i mean look at bruce
jenner the guy was going through this
mental strife all these years and then
like you just never know people are
going to he won the decathlon he's he
must be the healthiest guy ever not
mentally you never know so be more
empathetic is what mark is also saying i
think which is something that i've had
to work thank you for sure good
translator yeah yeah i'm like chewbacca
you're han solo
you
translate it to the masses something
about the jews i don't know
hawaiian um also
this episode's out that means that matt
and my documentaries out mark's got a
big role in it uh it's called full
capacity it's on my youtube channel it's
gonna be uh really good so i hope you
guys watch it uh give it a thumbs up
share it send it to a friend mark's in
it taylor tomlinson colin quinn ronnie
chang ray romano david tell sam j chris
redd so many uh
volcanoes
christa stefano so many of your fame
favorite people in it matt did such a
great job with it
it's kind of a follow-up to the rooftop
thing we did and uh give a shout out to
the editor too
comedian eric scott eric scott knocked
it as a killer yeah knocked it out i
mean that's without him this one exists
without him and not only that it
wouldn't have the ark and the story that
it has without it
he really
it's nice when a comedian edits
something because they understand where
to cut they understand how to give it a
story they understand how to give it an
arc and like i'm very proud of what he
did i screened it for mark and mark said
oh this is paste like a com uh comedian
set yes and it's like oh it's perfect
blocked out perfectly like this section
this section this section comes around
at the end it's really well done
i like i liked it i i saw i got misty i
mean it's it's a great
time capsule for that moment it's about
one of them when the pandemic you know
when clubs just opened in new york and
what we'd all been through as comics and
and you know and kind of getting back
into it we're all rusty it's kind of
that whole ride so i hope people liked
it yes
yes and if you want to see what new york
comedy is like i feel like you captured
it pretty damn well
so here here and uh
to norm come on
the norm the one of the funniest guys
ever one of my heroes so sad i
i know it's been a week now since the
news is out but we just found out so uh
check out his stuff i mean that's the
only thing you can do
yeah one of the greats another great
take it easy uh plug some data on the
road
come see us be hilarious
at uh all kinds of
nashville i'm at zanies love that club
love that town
uh comedy connection in providence
comedy on state in wisconsin uh
rochester new york
let's see
portland helium laugh boston good rooms
oh yeah break california vancouver bc
new orleans royal oak michigan all
atlanta buckhead theater all kinds of
dates hopefully uh we got a netflix
cooking on november 1st so keep keep an
eye out for that we have two specials
online check out the doc where are you
gonna be there fatty saint louis
indianapolis springfield missouri
uh
chicago denver phoenix
sf
uh
small theater in new york coming up too
so keep your eyes open on that
and then uh what else uh let's go on the
11th yeah i got sf yeah yeah all these
tickets are at samrell.com shows and
then we also got um
and we also got uh buffalo and dallas in
december uh samurail.com shows see ya
yeah we're gonna do a quick one for
normal just a quick little one we gotta
do it we got some great we weren't gonna
drink this episode but [ __ ] man you
gotta honor one of the greats one of the
toes just a toast for him
give me that angel's envelope do you
have a thing i'll be fine
i got some coffee in here we'll be good
you can do a coffee yeah it's just a
little backwash
never hurt anybody this is good
hey to uh one of the great comedians of
all time and uh we love you norm
you got that right big fan hero
all right pete
[Music]
you